china's in the middle of its fourth
outbreak tied to the more infectious
delta variant in the past five months
it's sweeping across the entire country
more than half of its provinces are
already dealing with coronavirus cases
more significantly both beijing and
shanghai have infections that are
happening currently within their city
limits in shanghai officials closed
disneyland and tested more than 32 000
people
keeping toddlers and families there
until nearly midnight
just because someone had traveled to
shanghai from a different province in
the end none of the people who were at
disneyland actually had the virus in
beijing officials have closed schools
because one person a staff member at a
beijing primary school was infected
that staff member had gone to have a
booster shot thereby
exposing other workers from different
schools we've heard reports that
officials closed down the schools and
kept the students there in some cases
allowing parents to come bearing
blankets to keep their kids safe
throughout the night
[Music]
almost every other country in the world
that had been pursuing a zero tolerance
policy for kovid has given up at this
point we know that australia and new
zealand in particular were very
successful
singapore as well
all three of those places have said that
they realize that because the more
infectious delta variant can spread more
quickly and can get through defenses
that previously stopped it they realize
that they're not going to be able to
actually maintain zero coveted cases
going forward so all of those locations
are learning to live with the virus in
some cases they are easing
[Music]
australia with a different vaccination
level is also doing the same thing new
zealand is still trying to keep
coronavirus under control but it has
said that it realizes that long term
that approach will not be successful and
it does plan to start allowing people in
more freely in the future
we believe that china is going to stay
shut down until the beijing olympics
china is very committed to having a
successful olympics particularly
following on the heels of the tokyo
games so they don't want to do anything
that's going to make it easier for the
virus to start spreading